yeah what welcome uh that's the wrong
way
don't want to see my microphone yeah
hello and welcome to this video which is
a rapid game on [ __ ] so wide f6 and
then see what happens
I don't know alright yeah but I'm not
used to it
well I should do this right this is a
little bit better during the game I have
to use them so um I could do something
else right I mean with a bit more time
on my hands what can I do
maybe they play a Kings inion Matsu
bushi is the point okay
no country information pull up so we got
the Kings Indian time control is 15 plus
3 I would actually can do is I can play
this this is an interesting line now
offering Y transpose into an abalone
with d5 if you castles I can take and
transpose it into more oxy bind this is
something interesting interesting
transposition because it's not
completely clear that the white player
has some knowledge of this opening
there's an important consideration with
some lines and sometimes you can
transpose into something it's highly
different and even though maybe the
objective value of the transposition is
ya not fantastic I mean you don't need
to love the Roxy bond with black but you
need to consider sometimes em ok now we
get it
and we'll see how he plays this I mean
it's possible that you have some idea
here of course but you never know he
might have never played this position
before in his life
so here Bishop III years the most common
choice light c2 is also possible of
course it's there are little differences
here if he goes night c2 now I have
Knight to d7 threatening well
threatening is a strong word but
intending here to double his pawns and
it's something that he has to think
about if he wants to allow this
disruption of the screen side if you
place Bishop e3 now and I play Bishop d7
then night c2 is a different story
I go here if he now plays Knight c2 it's
a different story because then there's
no Knight d7 and he you will never have
to worry about this double porn issue
night c2 now is the move that I am
playing in this position and we have
very nice score with it only recently it
helped me to to win in the final round
of the little open and that was a real
important game the difference was
getting nothing or getting one of the
main prizes so and I won this against
the 2400 freedom master
okay now Point has played Age 3 after
which I have captured and played Bishop
c6 in general black is happy to trade
one or two sets of minor pieces because
of his basem
disadvantage and Age 3 is actually I
mean I understand he maybe was worried
about some knight reform but h3 is
move that now now we have to play
something that he maybe doesn't
necessarily want to play before his
attacked and again he cannot play a
three now you cannot play f3 and h3 in
the same position at least it would
weaken the dark square so much that you
don't want to do it so he goes to f3 of
course white is still fine I'm not
saying that something wrong the average
often times wide wants to play a three
and after a three this is not we are not
that tempting anymore
so here 97 isn't is a normal-looking
move however he might take and play
deform in this position and I'm not sure
that I'm okay with that
I'm thinking about a five and then
Knight to d7 in general trading dark red
bishops is desirable here again because
of the lack of space you want to trade
however after 85 I wonder if he has e5
that's a move that looks a tad annoying
to me however I can take on f3 Queen
takes and then 937 oh I got a network
error okay so it's it's better yeah I
think it works him so II 5 I can take on
a3 Queen takes 97 and then he's in some
sort of health pin and ever get the e5
pawn in exchange for the b7 pawn which
normally should be a good trade even
though sometimes these kind of trades
can be okay for the site giving up the
central pawn because sometimes if you
have no central pawn like let's say we
trade B pawn against a pawn I can
actually do that I forget about this in
such a situation I have to send two
pawns which is nice in general but they
don't move forward all that much because
whatever I move
will create weaknesses and sometimes
then you can just pressure rise on those
open files so it's not always a clear
indication that it V and upon that say
that this is unfavorable you have to to
trade a center pawn against a relatively
flank pawn it's not always the case so
let's see what Matsu bushi is doing one
thing that I mentioned earlier on with
the transposition into the maroc see
that it's not clear that them opponent
actually knows the opening I think this
actually turns out to be true because
he's spending a large amount of time and
this age 3 and Bishop f3 already
indicates that is not familiar with the
main line at least so proof let's
unpainted and see what he does
most normal would probably be a move
like b3 to make sure that if I try to go
a 4 that is got b4 reign above so a 4
let's say it plays b3 I go a 4 equals B
4 and that keeps the Queen side pawn
structure intact it's not necessary move
by any means but omits it's the most
unconventional however if he goes b3 and
I go 97 he would be absolutely committed
to trade because well there should be
three eggs to the night oh that that me
with this is something that I definitely
am happy to see because now here the
dark squares here are weakened
tremendously I have to understand that
b4 is before it's very obvious weakness
in some way Loonette there's no pawn
controlling it let me play that move we
have to do it anyway and then explain
but there's also c5 s also we can't pay
for indirectly because now you never
will get a pawn to b4 to control it in
with the pawn back on a - there's
potentially a 3 B form
try to evict a knight coming there and
this is not on anymore
what
the big concern for why it is him that
with another poll on a light square if
one two three important pawns on light
squares then I think that white has to
worry about is that that Bishop on a
three might become a real problem piece
in the long run this is a very nice
position for black it is still extremely
solid for white so it's not like I'm
winning two clay here so but this whole
opening is geared towards you have very
patient nuvaring then you try to and ya
get into a strategically favorable
position let's see what's going on now
I'm expecting to India for check to make
me go back looks very natural to
centralize the Queen on the other hand
and I will go back to g8 I cannot go e5
if I would be strategically interesting
but it bloodthirsty six okay goes to e -
hmm yeah now how to how to play 95 looks
extremely normal here I just wonder if
if he's got five available I can take f3
Queen takes D takes e5 I don't think I
don't think he has enough
currently there is not there's nothing
threatened ready I'm going to do this
move him just to protect you seven and
just in case of let's say I could be
Queen to b6 and he goes ninety-five that
I don't have to worry about this pawn
it's not absolute necessity to it it is
a move that generally fits into this
position okay okay one so if I move the
knight you will go G five so I'm going
to stay tuned with the night on d7 and
protect a prepare prepare something that
Queen to b6 Queen b6 can be interesting
to before then ninety-five an
interesting strategic idea here is to
play e5 and maneuver the night let go c5
e 64 that would be great again
getting a knight into that big big
square on the form okay so well this is
actually giving me a tempo here yeah if
I go night to c5 now I mean Queen B -
there is 93 winning the exchange
95 e 593 m in this is not enough yeah I
think outsiders mean the night wants to
be on that square and he doesn't have a
fantastic way of covering things hmm
okay but now now I can I can consider
going to be six even though then lightly
high of 95 will probably be played what
I had in mind was he five now say
anything is there anything against this
that he can do looked you one light is
six is called Bishop g4 maybe huh but 94
is a good move
yeah the rukon c8 actually now can be a
bit silly after evironment okay let's
say i go five he goes Bishop g4 rook to
c7 v that doesn't look all that great
actually
I didn't really and didn't really
appreciate that when I went when I
played hook to him look to c8 that this
can be a little bit of a liability it's
got this e5 idea I mean if I go if I've
Bishop g4 g7 I can kick him out with h5
always okay so let's do it
an important point of this move is that
if he goes 95 I'm happy to take it
that's a different situation than with
the route on e7 the point is only 7 that
he goes 95 and I take it he takes with
the e pawn and then you might pressurize
my e7 pawn now the point is only 5 no
problem at all I mean such a situation
with 95 Bishop takes it takes like and
almost always resolve with going a 5
pawn takes rook takes yeah and so if you
imagine this back here in 95 i taked it
takes e5 takes rook takes is usually
okay but it's difficult to play form for
an advantage in such a situation
okay now 96 on Bishop g4 I have 94
should be 494 m should be should be okay
I'm not totally happy with this I mean I
probably I probably should have done
this a bit differently like can I do
this one maybe 95 I don't don't like
this so much in with hindsight set crew
be six or something I don't know it's
something to be checked later somehow I
feel like if he is precise now he should
be should be very okay I don't quite
don't quite I can't put my finger on it
how exactly to do it yeah okay here 94
is going to be played the exchange tag
is nothing much but what I'm fearing
it's a little bit is that if he can
trade night against night yeah but this
isn't this isn't that great I think I
take here and I take it takes you three
ante forces hanging also I can also take
the bishop 95 I mean this is good yeah
yeah but take the bishop 95 now that's
it's not not really is it grade okay no
this is fine and now this is the only
move and the question is what to do now
rook takes is tempting in some way
because it's a temple but Bishop takes a
TechSoup
okay that looks pretty promising I don't
know
so Luke takes Quincy to something Queen
f6 I can support this pawn a bishop
takes looks like the farm war natural
moves what is there is there anything
else entirely
there's Smoove f5 actually if I go f5 in
this position he has to play Bishop f3 I
take with the pawn bishop G form
h5 and this is the bishop I win the
bishop yeah I win the bishop here it's
trapped let's let's check it would be
kind of silly to play this and then it
doesn't work because Bishop takes is
clearly also pretty good ok f5 he has no
checks on anything I mean my position is
quite ok in terms of coordination so
Bishop f3 I take it I do threaten to
take it let's no loogie one because the
aide is covered so like f5 Bishop here
takes yes and will be one I can take it
as the eighth is covered so it takes
Bishop g4 h5 and the bishop has no
squares you can sacrifice of course on
an h5 takes takes Queen takes then Queen
f6 is
perfectly safe I have queen g6 coming up
u3 coming up okay so I have five should
should do it as the difference between
rapid game and the Blitz game in the
Blitz game I probably just would've
played we should be form
maybe shows that I'm technically not
sharp enough sometimes but I probably
would have displayed it there forever so
if I win the piece and it you know the
bishop on g4 is a little bit odd so it's
not totally surprising or like coming
out of the blue this idiom so we should
have three I'll take it just quickly map
it there's nothing nothing to check
anymore and there's no square simply
okay and what we can check here is the
best move now
this isn't interesting a question I was
thinking Queen f6 but this is also very
much an idea
I am the text the Queen on Queen G form
I'm I can actually do both Queen g5 or
g5 Queen g5 had an additional ready to
play see to answer if the Queen let's
say goes to well okay in the White Queen
has no decent square anyway and now to
see a door something and I can just
place it to and promote but York g5 also
looks very promising there is this e3
idea as well to open up the bishop and
then suddenly get an attack on G 225
however is extremely convincing yet it
basically has the trade Queens and then
I'm just a piece out pretty much even
though after Queen G 425 takes takes
rook c1 he will very likely win this
pawn on c3 which is a bit of a shame
it's not the pawn that I want to give up
necessarily let's see what he plays most
likely it's maybe Queenie too
keep the Queens on the board form some
way gasps wiggling chances mmm yep and
he plays it so what is the next move I
think maybe you'll see Wallace's
intention I mean this is Ella this makes
sense anyway bring the Queen when the
Queen into the game and III becomes an
option preventing books you want so
there are a couple of things in favor of
this move
okay there's also III it's on the cards
and III threatening Nate I probably
would need to play a three then which is
not very attractive so how do we wind if
you place that same yeah what does he
play III know then I go III as well yeah
here III is interesting threatening made
again and again he has no check F 3 I
can take with the bishop I can play -
yeah this is winning
I think this wins
f/32 special takes is good
and so here this is cute we should be
for as probably most convincing there is
no cheque or anything to to annoy me so
let's just pick up more material Queen
takes of course also look good okay so I
can take this with check and prevent see
to next step for promotion
[Music]
and many ways to do it
this also threatens Bishop g2 with maid
so Bishop g2 has made and then worked in
one maid or mate with the Queen
okay thanks for the game matzo bushy
things so let's say I have a look at the
scheme and there is a sport and let's
have a look I think here I want to
change the vuo so that you can actually
see the engine so we have does no oxy
bind by transposition getting a mainline
mainline position here yeah I mean h3
it's not a bad weather I said it's just
like it's actually the engines choice
did it which thing is kind of funny
so h3 then the most common movie our
2012 night see - okay so h3 I'm happy to
trade absolutely take-take-take
in our Bishop f3 which is the normal
choice um
the other moves also makes some sense of
course Creed III Queen c2 it leads to
very similar similar structures in the
engine by the way generally Fame is wide
in the maracas see Bank because of the
space engines always some evaluate space
quite highly and this is not
unreasonable just something to keep in
mind I've analyzed this a little bit
with computers and sometimes the engine
even gives advantages for widened
positions where I think there's nothing
even though I'm in general the engines
evaluate those position quite well
sometimes something I really stood an
advantage I don't think so and then
slowly if you go deeper
um the regulation goes down so we should
have three
I mean you can argue with this move the
engine doesn't like it all that much
anyway I go here yeah this again I
didn't like so much because you can take
and play before that's what I already
mentioned and the computer agrees that
white is better here it's just annoying
if you don't get the square here and
this is something that is a very yeah
that is a very short lifter square for
the foreman idea get you get it expelled
quickly so I go eight five that's the
better move you played a form yeah and
this is your order to see the eval going
down the engine recognizes how weak
those squares are yeah I think what I
suggested b3 in the in during the game
and after this it's important to
understand that now I mean Bishop III is
one during the night so he's committing
to this trade and the danger that white
face is in general he is that if we
trade more pieces and I get to an ending
I might have the situation where this
Bishop isn't all that great even though
with the space white often still has an
okay position it's not like it's totally
terrible also however a4 helps me a lot
in that regard many endings now will be
much more favorable in comparison one
thing that is often underestimated is
that these weaknesses they can often be
useful with the king if you imagine an
ending macking might just invade which
is not possible if he is not playing a
four but like a 3 B 3 and so on it then
before is covered so 97 and he decided
to take which is probably they're not
much choice anyway and now yeah I
expected Queen to deform so I would like
King g8 I'm not sure
f 6 is not terribly bad but as long as
you don't have to play it you don't want
to
one reason is if you go F 6 in such a
position after subsequent 95 you have
trouble taking this after he takes you
would have huge weakness o CM so it
drops you have some flexibility I would
have just gone to G 8 and then we have a
similar position to the game one problem
with this Queen position is said after
coming that c5 actually threatened
before or threatened in the a pawn so
it's a little bit uncomfortable here
also that's creepy 6 as the engine
points out in a line where I try to
trade Queens and this is again rather
favorable for me to trade so we went
Queen e2 instead and now where you can
you can argue p8 was awaiting news
basically improving slightly engine
wants to go Knights you find immediately
yeah I mean I saw that but I wasn't
entirely sure about this I saw this but
here I wasn't totally clear to me if I
have a very good setup so let's say he
attacks it and I wasn't quite sure where
to go this always 95 coming and it's a
little bit lose this position and with
the with the night being unprotected the
engine likes it
probably just a pawn ok Matt so this is
not a very time-sensitive position you
can play improvement moves this is some
plate and now at the group c8 yeah again
I didn't like it all that much a little
bit later because it somehow some of
these places to look in some way I mean
it call it's not terrible but this is
sir this is what I also considered I
wasn't sure about this the thing is I
mean I can take and I'm okay here but I
wasn't sure on
how good my chances are to play for an
advantage okay look it's not a terrible
v3 and 95 now e5 doesn't work I mean I
thought at least like this doesn't work
right it does feel somehow I can check
here right and that was our that that is
possible
okay so that doesn't pose a threat and
now I went u5 what I wanted to do anyway
goes here and now 96 yeah and yet here
was the situation where I thought ok if
he plays over well now he is probably
fine and then the engine gives a couple
of equal positions
yeah Bishop g4 94 yeah and this is
actually what I was thinking and if he
ain't taking what's wrong with if he
does that intending to trade off my
knight this cannot be bad for him
absolutely not look see 792 and now this
position is a little bit a little bit
wacky yeah I think I probably have to go
for this he's not threatening to take
probably because of roopd 784 I say okay
and that's a bit uncomfortable I mean
I'm not losing this pawn I don't think
that this is not not that nice
yeah I miss played that slightly hand
absolutely I probably should have played
it differently the engine suggested e6
let make some sense actually had to
start with this and only later decide if
you want to go E 5 or not and that
that's why you should have done I mean
this is the real thing and this is the
real problem that was just losing
Mexican try to see that this is a forced
Lynam like here here and now this f5
wins apiece so in SMSs blunders apiece
now a bishop was strapped so t4 was was
the decisive mistake basically get that
reasonably quickly I mean it looks the
night looks menacing but you you get it
you get it trade it off pretty quickly
yeah then I think the rest was pretty
straightforward I don't think I made any
mistake while I looked it looked an
organized enough and I think I didn't
plan anything into the pond if I made
territory early and it I am Bishop
Queen 83 also was pretty strong okay
well it was a win so the main thing is
that somewhere around here I probably
should be a bit more precise and have
better chances to to play for an
advantage maybe I mean it's nothing
special it white is very solid but you
have some things already some things are
already em let's say
something's happened already that are in
black favor and the trade of the bishops
you put many pawns on light square so
they're the first steps there are the
first steps from maybe for black - to
try to do something at least so I would
like to be better in this position then
then something like this where why did I
give you a little bit more comfortable
ok guys thanks for watching